so hey everyone my name is Alejandra
today we'll be talking about the past
present and future of JavaScript engines
we will start by the year 58 1958 with
one of the earliest published
just-in-time compilers that was achieved
- Lisp the programming language Lisp and
in the year or in the decade 1960s the
wind went many virtual machines around
and note in that by beautiful machines
in this talk I will refer to the type of
virtual machines that translate from one
instruction set to another instruction
set there are other types of beautiful
machines that virtualizes operating
systems and hardware we won't cover
those virtual machines today so one of
the benefits of introducing metal
machines around this time is that you
could have some of your code of your
implementation to stay the same
say in this case the transformation from
code to an intermediate representation
will stay the same for different CPU
architectures and remember that around
this fan there was not a monopoly or a
CPU architecture that was predominant
over others there were a couple CPU
architectures lying around and you would
have to actually write your own compiler
for a programming language for all of
those CPU architectures so this type of
peripheral machines
allowed you to just write the
transformation for intermediate
representation to machine code on a
case-to-case basis
in the 70s Pascal was invented which was
an imperative programming language and I
started to gain some attention as well
these an overly simplistic diagram is
how a virtual machine would look like at
that time and it wasn't conceived that
brittle machines could be as fast as
other compiled programming languages
like C in this decade also a small tag
was created a language designed
specifically for educational purposes
and it was authored by Alan Kay the
small talk code was also executed in a
beautiful machine and it is an
object-oriented programming language
it's BM was subject of a few enhancement
over time like just-in-time compilation
later in the 80s other important things
happening during the eighties was the
programming language South which was
created in the year 86 by David Unger
and Brandon Smith who then later pioneer
some of the concepts that we will see
into the virtual machines space two key
concepts are were born with South on one
side adaptive optimization and on the
other side generational garbage
collection these T concepts just send
itself and we're later applied see the
JVM and our percent in all major
browsers we have today with some
differences
by this time I started what we will call
the first wave of adaptive optimization
and this first wave
there was a profiler involved that
marked some of the functions to be sent
to a just-in-time compiler in this
example on the left say you are
executing a function a thousand times
then the profiler could identify that
function as a target for optimization or
to be run through a compiler in the 90s
there were other improvements over
existing runtimes like small talk and
self a small talk being actually
implemented in production systems but
the most iconic advance from my
perspective were the invention of these
programming languages python being quite
older it was born in the nineteen while
both Java and JavaScript were created in
the year 1995 by that time it was not
called JavaScript which is kind of weird
the increase on this innovation was not
just a coincidence personal computers
which previously were way WAY expensive
I started to become more affordable by
this time from this graph we can see
that the slope starts to get pronounced
around the 90s and goes all the way up
like that to 2005 for 2010 during this
period period it became he began the
second wave of adaptive optimization we
was which was adding multiple levels to
what we previously saw before by having
multiple just-in-time compilers say on
the previous case with a simple
just-in-time compiler are being applied
for
engine running maybe a thousand times
and the other optimizing compiler for
functions that would go over fifty
thousand a hundred thousand times in the
2000s we served the web first big steps
multiple browsers were released like
Firefox in the 2002 an opera changing to
a free-to-use approach and I actually
remember you said an opera I was a nice
browser like fast JavaScript execution
fast table startup as well who else here
remember using upper okay wasn't that
bad
so the web pushed JavaScript engines by
that time you could do all sorts of
things now on the web like logging to
chat rooms and talk with hundreds of
people simultaneously simultaneously you
could browse your emails you can
navigate through maps on your browser as
well for those that are looking at me
like what you're talking about may
that's not something you know trust me
it is near it started around this time
it is fairly to say by that time Java
sock you been JavaScript engines were
not catching up with other virtual
machines like the JVM or Java Virtual
Machine if you remember the graph of
personal computers growth these was
where it was growing rapidly but at the
beginning of the decade we started with
this percentage of world's population
with access to Internet it was still
very low 5% now we will go through a
couple of diagrams on how javascript
engines would look like around that time
javascriptcore being the engine for
safari and again in this overly
simplistic
engine we see an interpreter which will
take the the JavaScript and we'll run
that JavaScript with node code being
generated whatsoever at that time also
now optimisation either for SpiderMonkey
around that time they also had an
interpreter but they would also have an
optimizing compiler that would target
these hot paths we were talking about if
a function was being executed too many
times and p8 at the beginning he was
created around 2008 I think chrome later
was released later but it didn't had an
interpreter initially he had two
compilers one for compiling the
JavaScript core as fastest as possible
right away and an optimizing compiler
that would compile these functions that
were executing too many times by this
time we are also stepping into you what
is called the third wave of adaptive
optimizations where BMS would profile
the current execution not only to
identify which paths are hot and Optus
optimize them but also to know how to
optimize in other textbooks these is
called online feedback directed
optimization these strategies that we're
talking now we're later first
implemented in hotspot JVM and would
then later on being permitted in
JavaScript engines
from all the periods that we will see
today these in a way is the easier of
them all to describe because we all been
through that decade but at the same time
the amount of things happening during
this decade it is so high that is very
hard to keep track of them if you
remember the graph of personal computers
around 2010 is where it starts to
stagnate but we still see an increase on
Internet users actually in 10 years it
grew from 5% to 28% are growing
outgrowing I believe very every
projections that people had around that
time the number of websites it also grew
from less than 200 millions to almost
800 millions or more in the year 2014 or
2015 what we are seeing here is a graph
that aggregates smartphones by the
amount of memory and it's dated for the
year 2017 dark gray bars represent
devices with one gigabyte of memory
following there's a yellow bar with
devices that have two gigabytes and the
light gray is devices with three
gigabytes of memory I'm not sure if you
can reach out to see the labels below in
the graph but developing countries like
Argentina Brazil Colombia Nigeria South
Africa have devices with just one
gigabyte first in the rest of the
countries listed here at least we see
devices with
yuuji divides run first but by a great
distance compared with the number of
devices with three gigawatts of memory
or more now if we dig a little deeper
into some of the trade trade-offs does
that just-in-time compilers had to deal
with will found that as we apply more
optimizations the code generated starts
to grow and internal representations
start to get more complicated you need
to keep track of more things happening
either if you in line if you take
something outside from a loop whatever
apps optimization you do it often
results in memory usage increase the
second trade off that compilers have to
deal with is the latency introduced in
execution time the best optimizations
available will introduce a higher late
latency compared to not applying any
optimizations at all on these scale on
the extreme left on the extreme left we
will find interpreters because those
would not require any generation of code
and would only require that parsing of
the code you have for them to start up
if we go through our engines during this
time or during this decade we will see a
couple of changes and improvements over
them a spider monkey being the engine
for Firefox went through a couple of
changes in just six or seven years they
moved from one compiler to
two compilers and then later on they
change the optimizing one in this case I
a monkey which is the layout they are
using today and the interesting thing
about spider monkey bailouts or the
optimizations would go up to the
baseline just-in-time compiler instead
of going all the way back to the
interpreter for chakra core the X
Microsoft edge engine it's kind of more
difficult to describe over time because
they open search these virtual machine
just on 2016 about at that time they had
an interpreter and T compilers one for
simple optimizations and one that offer
the complex optimizations but what can
assume that they also had their share of
experimentations before deciding for
these final architecture that we see
here javascript core is one of the
engines that changed as well during this
time but they didn't change it
drastically they introduced the second
compiler around 2009/2010 which is DFG
or stands for data flow graph
just-in-time compiler they also have a
simple just-in-time compiler or
interpreter and they switch to having
three compilers instead of one by 2016
FTL called faster-than-light with the
type inference and type specializing
compiler so all the
best optimizations being targeted but
that new compiler in the case of v8 it's
one of the most interesting cases
because in my perspective it suffered
from the most radical changes over over
time by 2016 we see that they still
hadn't added an interpreter and they
would still have a parser that would
output an abstract syntax tree and would
compile that as fast as possible for the
optimizing compiler that was crankshaft
and for the optimizations the code would
go back to the baseline
just-in-time compiler if we would graph
those two in the scale than we had
before
crankshaft will be closer to the right
and the baseline compiler would be to
the left but not to the extreme left
because compiling code would still have
some latency we still have some overhead
for starting up by 2017 pietà switched
completely to these new architecture of
course they didn't just turn a switch
from overnight they introduced some
changes progressively they did all their
testing that the needed to and once they
felt very confident with this new
architecture they changed from having T
compilers to having one interpreter in
this diagram called ignition and
turbofan which is replacing what we
really previously was
crunch up it would be closer to the
right if we would graph that on a scale
and comparing with the previous one now
the interpreter in nation would stand
further to the left it would have less
the start-up time for JavaScript Iran we
haven't talked into you too much for
garbage collection or their approach but
nowadays if we will go through all major
browsers we would be able to say that BA
and SpiderMonkey use a precise strategy
so they count exactly or they know
exactly how many allocations they did
during the execution with when
javascriptcore and check our core do you
a conservative approach which is looking
at memory positions and determine saying
how how confident they they think it
would need to be collected or not but
they all use generational strategy the
one that was introduced by self in the
80s this extensive gain in users and
market penetrations in multiple devices
also came with the whole set of new
problems JavaScript and JavaScript
engines are started to become a target
for vulnerabilities that would allow
attackers to get or extract data or to
gain code execution on multiple devices
previous photo was from actually a RTV
for this year alone there were granted
bounties for six sixty thousand US
dollars for an integer overflow boom
vulnerability on Amazon echo another one
around 20,000 US dollars for another
integer overflow in a TV that would
allow attackers to get our Berbers shell
and that's just this year in this band I
know
Pantone had also an event in Vancouver
and they released other bounties as well
so for what's next a few caveats
before we move on these are all my
observations and have in mind that I'm
not subject matter expert on this field
I don't work on a daily basis on
JavaScript engines my goal is to share
with you all the point of view for a
developer on how things could look like
in the future just-in-time compilers
will keep getting better but I don't see
them overcoming the constraints that we
talked before on memory specifically
because of how we write software we are
down drawn into making short live
allocations which is one of the panel
and an intent pillars for generational
garbage collection the strategy that all
JavaScript engines are using today
interpreters on the other side as a tool
with the lowest latency that we have
found or that we have discussed today
will continue to to have its place as
long as we don't find something faster
for startup times
one of the things that I certainly hope
to see more and I do believe we are on
the right track
for getting there is better
collaboration between benders working on
JavaScript engines with other parts of
the web ecosystem like tooling projects
this year there was a blog post written
by DB 18 on how json dot parse could be
between 10 to 50 percentage faster than
parsing just a straight object little
and it is not something the VA team was
encouraging as developers to go and
change on our repositories but rather
full tools like web pack to include that
in their logic for bungling and it's
also interesting because this is not
Khurana specific it would yield
performance improvements on other
browsers like Firefox or Safari we have
also seen innovation happening on the
field of JavaScript engines with very
specific goals like the harness engine
designed for react native applications
or juries creep and duct-tape first I
started happening with them with very
low resources specific JavaScript
engines and I believe it could be a good
approach or at least an interesting one
to see with node an option for node
could be having different set of flags
or configuration values to let the
engine know it is running on a long
lifespan context I do know there are
flags to say modify the limits of memory
for b8 but that doesn't actually change
how the engine manages memory internally
these stop in for the last June and we
can see that many of the efforts that
have have been in play rendered an
enormous effect on helping people to use
utilize research online and I consider
that a win-win if as we keep this number
going high services and companies will
be able to sell to more people and
people will be able to reach out to more
resources knowledge and other services
online as well I hope this random help
to get an ID on some of the decisions
that were happening during all these
decades and hope that covered some of
the fundamental concepts to get where we
are today if you want to go and see the
slides or the resources that I use for
this talk you can find them all in this
link if you have any follow-up questions
you can reach out to me online or in the
hallway that's it thank you for your
time
[Applause]